is the owner of the Dallas Mavericks he
is also on one of the top television
shows love me some shark tanks moving to
Sunday night's count up on ABC starting
on October 1st he's Mark Cuban back here
in the Rich Eisen show how are you mark
great rich are you doing buddy I am
doing I am doing great
so I guess let's jump right into it what
did you think mark when you saw the news
that the Pacers had charged the Lakers
with tampering what did you think of
when you saw that I mean it's hard to
tamper and it's even harder to prove
because I mean it's not like players
aren't aware of everything that's going
on and and their agents aren't aware of
everything that's going on within
different organizations and their agents
know everybody in all the different
organizations so it's really hard to do
and hard to prove but I see where the
Pacers are coming from you know you just
want to make sure that there's nothing
that that you don't know about or that
that could have gone wrong so it's kind
of like a hedge just in case but I doubt
anything will come of it yeah I mean how
much do hard feelings come into play
when you're an owner or you're in the
front office of our team that's the
Clippers about the Andre you know but
John Jay Jordan I mean you look at your
team and you know who drives the team
and when when something like that
happens look like what when we lost Eve
Nash way back when you know there were
some things that I thought were a little
bit questionable but it was just the
price of tea in China right it's just
the way it worked so you do you do have
your feelings are you do get a little
bit mad you do want to immediately react
you know and try to you know create some
type of retribution but usually you calm
down but the Pacers are a great
organization the really Kevin Prichard
knows what he's doing so maybe he has
something that we're not aware of no I
you know before you joined on the phone
line I did mention about how you were on
the business end if you will of a
tampering fine from the league back in
2010 from merely answering the question
about LeBron in a normal way of course
you're going to be interested in
somebody of LeBron Jameses stature so
what what what does the league tell
folks in your position about what you
can say and what you can't say on front
either for you they're pretty clear
right but sometimes like that interview
um
it just didn't even cross my mind that
this will connect the two when they
asked me about it and so sometimes you
get caught but that was also a little
bit of a different era I mean David
stirrer loved to find me just because he
needed the doughnut money you know it's
kind of a little little battle that went
on between us and Adams a lot different
you know that um there's got to be
intent with David if you just broke the
letter of the law you're going to not
the intent and he was going to nail you
especially me so you know I think Adam
animal look the see if there's any
intent we'll see what happened when was
the last time you spoke to David Stern
mark I talk to him every now and then
actually I mean look I love David we bet
we but it has a lot and I disagreed on a
lot of things but I learned from him I
think he learned from me and I'm better
for it so we'll talk different types of
technologies he tried to keep up on
everything he's still really active in
investing in young entrepreneurs which
is a passion of mine so we'll talk about
a lot of cool stuff mark you've been
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
one of the pet peeves I had over the NBA
season of 2016-2017 mark was the the
resting of stars in cities where they
visit only once a lot of clipper fans
were excited to see LeBron didn't get to
see him do you think that that situation
has been rectified with the the new
schedule that was just announced last
week I'd say were 90% of the way there I
can't tell you how many years rich I've
been complaining to the league that we
can solve that problem by dealing with
the schedule and it took a few employees
rolling off of the NBA payroll before we
really got into the technology to do the
regression analysis that could solve all
that so I think we're not a hundred
percent of the way there but they
finally took into account that if you're
going to play a game on Thursday night
on TNT or Sunday afternoon on ABC
you probably shouldn't schedule again
the night before you know and so it
wasn't on the teams it was a hundred
percent on the NBA it was just made no
sense how we were doing our scheduling
so yeah I think Adams really gone a long
way towards fixing it but what would you
ever tell Rick Carlisle do not
test our top players when we're visiting
say Madison Square Garden or the one
time that you're visiting Washington DC
or Cleveland would you ever give that
directive to your coach no nope because
the bigger picture is still the bigger
picture and so we're trying to win
championships we'll try to accomplish
our goals and I'll probably talk to him
about it but if it's in line with our
goals you know we'll sell a whole lot
more tickets and have our fans a whole
lot more excited when we're
accomplishing those goals than any one
given game and honestly rich look as an
owner even if someone were arrest to
star when they come to Dallas the ones a
couple things I can't control when a
game start is how well we're going to
play whether or not somebody is hurt or
if you get hurt what the final score is
going to be etc but what I can control
is that there's so much more to go into
an NBA game than just the game you know
I say this all the time
you know when you go to a game football
or a spa you don't remember the scores
two touchdowns and dunks to shut you
remember who you are with you would
never waste built the jewelry chat and
those are the things that people
remember you know LeBron in Turkish
whispers don't begin think about to let
that said I don't care whether they play
or not it so I think the bigger picture
is do we invest enough to make every
experience a fan hat when they walk into
an NBA arena a great experience because
you know for LeBron has an off night or
LeBron is tweaked or dirt tweaked
something you're not going to get the
best of them anyways or they're tired
because this is a long season so we
can't you know I'm never going to tell
Rick what to do in terms of sitting or
not sitting guys but I'm always going to
invest and I'm always going to put an
emphasis on giving everybody great value
for their dollar when you come into the
American Airlines seven couple of more
minutes with Mark Cuban Mavericks owner
here on the Rich Eisen show let's talk
Mavs did you see the nba.com poll of
rookies asking the rookies who will win
what ricky of the year and Lanza ball a
placed to the winner Dennis Smith jr.
did you see that mark oh what a curse
you're talking about putting the jinx on
again I gotta tell you
junior Dennis jr. is phenomenal put
aside his athleticism I mean the Yogi's
ball handling is intellect for the game
he's already on synergy sports watching
great point guards learning from them
you know he's committed to getting
better every day he's just got that
mindset of a winner where he doesn't
just want to be an athlete with a motor
that plays basketball he wants to be a
basketball player with a great
basketball IQ that also happens to be an
amazing athlete and I think hopefully
that is what can set him apart now we're
not expecting miracles
you know season one but I think you
really have the chance to be something
special so what was it like in the draft
room when he was still on the board and
the Knicks were drafting what was it
like for you um let's just say it was a
happy ending any way you want it did
work out or or the fact that as I read
that the Knicks and Phil Jackson try to
serve him octopus or calamari and he was
turned off by that fact doing that right
I mean the thing about the draft there's
so many misdirection that that take
place from all teams and so you have a
good feel you know because what happens
is all the GM's talk to each other and
they try to play coy about their own
pick but they have no problem talking
about what they know from other teams so
you get a good sense on the board but
there's always a couple guys that you
aren't quite sure about and Dennis Smith
was one of them fraud he was top three
and off board going into the season and
then he got a bad rap on when North
Carolina State didn't have a good year
but all of our Intel all of our
conversations with him were top-notch
and so you know we were really happy
when he felt with two more questions for
you mark before before I let you go I
know what you've said about the NFL in
the past about hogs get slaughtered and
now they have a little bit of a problem
being a hockey shark tank is moving to
Sunday night's against Sunday Night
Football marker is this your way of
trying to slaughter the hog market
oh no thank god baby are
you know the good news is I mean shark
tanks still an incredible show it
actually we got a rock we've got a lot
of incredible guest richard branson and
so we're still going to be a great show
but yeah are we going to beat the NFL
are we going to take a notch out of them
no but the good news is you know
probably fifty five sixty percent of our
viewers are women and because of that
we're good counter-programming and for
the men who like to watch you know men
you know we're hoping they'll just DVR
and watch it within three or seven days
and so because the technology has kind
of changed the game if we do an L plus
seven and get good numbers we're all
gonna be there you go plus seven I love
it that's definitely a TV talk right
there and last one for you mark is there
a chance that I am talking to the 46th
president of the United States that
possible yeah I want to put it high on
my list of probabilities but we'll see
what happens I've got a lot of time to
decide I mean it's flattering the people
ask me and I appreciate it and there's
definitely a leadership void in this
country but I'm not jumping in you know
I've got I'm a big believer that you
don't just do it to try to pretend to be
a politician you have to have solutions
and I'm working on some projects if I
think they can turn into solutions then
yeah I'll do I don't think I have the
right answers that I want okay so there
is a chance in 2020 there's a Cuban
Stern ticket right David would be on the
ticket let's just say you're saying
there's a chance right that would truly
be the dumb and Dumberer king mark
thanks for calling in I look forward to
our next chat hope to see you when
you're in LA any time ready to thank
your participation you got a smart Cuban
at M Cuban on Twitter the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience
if you like that downloading around
please just if it's a memory thing just
delete other apps you don't need those
apps this app the Rich Eisen show app
you need that